♪ ♪
>> NOW HE IS BEGINNING HIS BIG,
BIG, AND MOST IMPORTANT JOURNEY.
THIS IS WHERE YOU ARE MEANT TO
BE RIGHT HERE TODAY AT THIS
CROSSROADS IN HISTORY.
>> I'M NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
>> HOW LONG WILL YOU STAY FOR?
>> AS LONG AS THE PRESIDENT LETS
ME.
I AM STILL HERE.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
2018 IS THE YEAR OF EXECUTION.
MY COMMISSION OF SECRETARY OF
STATE WILL TERMINATE AT MIDNIGHT
MARCH 31.
>> REX AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
WE GOT ALONG ACTUALLY QUITE
WELL.
BUT WE DISAGREED ON THINGS, SO
WE WERE NOT REALLY THINKING THE
SAME.
>> Bret: THE TIMELINE WE HAVE
IS THAT THE CHIEF OF STAFF
CALLED THE SECRETARY OF STATE
REX TILLERSON WHILE HE WAS
OVERSEAS AND SAID "GET READY.
YOU NEED EITHER STEP DOWN OR THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO ACT."
THE PRESIDENT DID ACT VIA
TWITTER.
THE FIRST ACKNOWLEDGMENT
OFFICIALLY SAYING MIKE POMPEO
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA WILL BECOME
OUR NEW SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE WILL DO A FANTASTIC JOB.
THANK YOU TO REX TILLERSON FOR
HIS SERVICE.
GINA HASPEL WILL BECOME THE NEW
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA.
THE FIRST WOMAN SO CHOSEN.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL.
FOUR MONTHS PLUS OGO, TWITTER
WAS A PLACE WHERE THE PRESIDENT
TOOK TWO TO DEFEND REX TILLERSON
FROM STORIES HE WAS ON HIS WAY
OUT THE DOOR.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN SPECULATING
THAT HE WOULD BE LEAVING SOON.
"WE WORK WELL TOGETHER.
AMERICA IS HIGHLY RESPECTED
AGAIN."
THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF OFFICIALS
RESIGNING OR BEING FIRED.
THE LIST IS CONTINUING.
THERE YOU SEE SOME OF THEM.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL IT
CONTINUE?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
STEVE HAYES, A.B. STODDARD, AND
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
>> THIS KIND OF INTERESTING,
FIVE MONTHS AGO IS AN ETERNITY
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> Bret: ONE WEEK SEEMS LIKE
AN ETERNITY.
>> MAY BE THE TWITTER-VERSE WAS
GETTING IT WRONG.
AN ARGUMENT THEY USE FOR WHILE
HE LIKES TO SURROUND HIMSELF
WITH THE YES-MEN IS POINTING TO
ALL OF THE NO MEN.
THEY HAVE HAD SERIOUS
DISAGREEMENTS FOR VERY LONG
TIME.
THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED IRAN
TODAY.
THE DIFFERENCES WERE
UNBRIDGEABLE.
HE DOESN'T SURROUND HIMSELF BY
YES-MEN.
HE HAS PEOPLE LIKE JIM MATTIS,
GARY COHN WHO DISAGREED WITH HIM
ON TARIFFS BUT THEY GOT A LOT
DONE TOGETHER.
I FIND THAT PARTICULAR
ACCUSATION TO BE UNFOUNDED.
>> Bret: THERE WAS REPORTED A
SUICIDE PACT, IF YOU WOULD,
BETWEEN TILLERSON AND MATTIS AND
I THINK MNUCHIN AT ONE POINT.
NOW THAT TILLERSON IS
EFFECTIVELY LEAVING.
IF YOU PUT UP THE BULLET POINTS
OF RIFFS, THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL
IS NUMBER ONE.
NORTH KOREA STRATEGY, THEY WERE
ON DIFFERENT PAGES EVEN THIS
WEEK.
THE QATAR BLOCKADE, CHINA
POLICY, RUSSIAN MEDDLING.
PARIS CLIMATE AGREEMENT AND THE
CHARLOTTESVILLE RESPONSE.
IT IS INTERESTING IT STARTED OUT
TILLERSON WITH HER TO BE SO
CLOSE TO RUSSIA AND THE PUTIN
FRIEND AND AS HE IS LEAVING,
HE'S THE GUY WHO WAS STANDING UP
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
AND THAT'S WHY HE'S LEAVING HIM
ACCORDING TO SOME.
>> EVERYONE LOOKS AGGRESSIVE ON
RUSSIA NEXT TO THE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU PUT MATTIS UP NOW, YOU
WOULD HAVE A BUNCH OF BULLET
POINTS ON WHICH HE DISAGREES.
PEOPLE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND NATIONAL SECURITY AND
FOREIGN POLICY HAVE SPOKEN MANY
TIMES.
IT'S A HALLMARK OF THIS FIRST
YEAR.
APART FROM POMPEO AND HASPEL,
HOW LITTLE REX TILLERSON WILL BE
MISSED AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
HOW LONG THIS WAS COMING.
IT WAS OBVIOUSLY UNTENABLE AND
THE PRESIDENT AND SECRETARY OF
STATE CAN'T DISAGREE THAT MUCH
ON POLICY.
IT HAS TO WORK.
SO IT HAS TO BE -- HE HAS TO BE
REPLACED.
IT IS THE WAY HE DID IT.
I THINK TODAY IS A REALLY DARK
DAY FOR THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK IT REFLECTED VERY POORLY
ON US.
UNLIKE CHARLIE, I AM
PRO-STABILITY.
IT WAS THE WAY HE DID IT, BY
HUMILIATING HIM.
WHICH IS CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY.
AND THE TIMING -- WHY DIDN'T HE
DO IT SIX WEEKS AGO?
THE TIMING WITH THE NORTH KOREA
SUMMIT IS TERRIBLE.
THE FURTHER DESTABILIZATION AND
DYSFUNCTION IS ALWAYS AN
ADVANTAGE TO OUR ADVERSARIES.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A CONSTANT
THEME.
I FIND IT FRIGHTENING.
>> Bret: STEVE, HOW IT WAS
DONE OBVIOUSLY, SECRETARY
TILLERSON TODAY DO NOT MENTION
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN HIS REMARKS
AS HE WAS EXITING THE WHICH IS
NOTABLE.
ON THE IRAN DEAL, IF PASSING
SENATE NOMINATION HEARINGS, AND
A VOTE, DIRECTOR POMPEO HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF OPPOSING THE
IRAN DEAL.
I ASKED HIM ABOUT IT NOT TOO
LONG AGO.
WHEN YOU ARE CONGRESSMAN POMPEO,
I ASKED YOU ABOUT THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT IS GOOD
OUT OF THIS DEAL?
>> I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING THAT
HAS PUT AMERICA IN A BETTER
POSITION AS A RESULT OF THIS
DEAL.
>> Bret: NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
THIS DECISION WHETHER TO
REAUTHORIZE THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL.
DO YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE TODAY?
>> MY ROLE IS A BIT DIFFERENT.
THIS IS WHAT I WOULD SAY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR ITS
VIEW THAT HE DOESN'T THINK THE
DEAL WAS WORTH A DARN.
>> Bret: THAT IS POMPEO'S
VIEW.
SEEMS LIKE WE ARE CLOSER TO
GETTING OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL
TODAY THAN WE WERE A WEEK AGO.
>> SOME KIND OF ATTEMPT OF A
FOLLOW-ON AGREEMENT WHERE YOU
BRUSH IN FRANCE, GERMANY AND THE
UNITED KINGDOM INTO SNAPBACK
SANCTIONS IN A SERIES OF OTHER
THINGS THAT MIGHT MAKE THE DEAL
MORE ENFORCEABLE.
SNAP INSPECTIONS OF MILITARY
SCIENCE, THINGS WERE NOT ABLE TO
DO NOW.
I BELIEVE POMPEO IS IN FAVOR OF
THAT AS OPPOSED TO JUST WALKING
AWAY FROM THE DEAL.
WHAT'S BEEN INTERESTING IS MIKE
POMPEO HAS SEEN HIMSELF, HE'S A
WEST POINT GRADUATE AND HE TAKES
SERIOUSLY THESE DIFFERENT LANES.
HE WAS NOT A POLICY ADVISOR TO
THE PRESIDENT.
IN THEIR MEETINGS, HE REPEATEDLY
SOUGHT FIRST TO RIDE THE PRESENT
WITH INTELLIGENCE IN A NONPOLICY
WAY.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD COME BACK TO
MIKE POMPEO AND ASKING FOR
POLICY ADVICE WHICH WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF AN UNCOMFORTABLE FIT.
I THINK POMPEO IS CLOSE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP PHILOSOPHICALLY
ON THIS RANGE OF ISSUES.
IN THAT SENSE, I THINK HE WILL
BE A MORE SERIOUS ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT AND REX TILLERSON WAS.
REX TILLERSON DISAGREED WITH THE
PRESIDENT SO MANY TIMES ON SO
MANY THINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT
STOPPED LISTENING TO HIM.
HANNAH'S INCIDENT, YOU HAVE
SOMEONE SMART, THOUGHTFUL, WHO
KNOWS THE ISSUES WELL AND WILL
HAVE THE PRESIDENT'S EAR.
MIKE POMPEO HAS BECOME A TRUSTED
ADVISOR TO DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT ALSO
TRUSTS GINA HASPEL.
SHE HAS BEEN GIVING HIM HIS
PRESIDENTIAL DAILY BRIEFINGS.
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED A
RELATIONSHIP.
SHE IS WELL RESPECTED INSIDE THE
CIA.
THE PROCESS HERE IS A DISASTER
AND IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
BUT THE OUTCOME I THINK IS A
GOOD OUTCOME.
>> Bret: IS THERE ANY DOUBT
THIS IS GOING TO BE -- THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TRY TO
USE THESE HEARINGS FOR A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
BUT IS THERE ANY DOUBT THAT BOTH
OF THESE FOLKS CAN GET THROUGH,
POMPEO AND HASPEL?
>> HASPEL HAS THE BIGGER
PROBLEMS BECAUSE OF HER
INVOLVEMENT IN THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION TECHNIQUE STUFF
HAS MORE OF AN UPHILL BATTLE.
FROM MY CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE ON THE HILL TODAY, EVEN
SHE WILL GET THROUGH WITH SOME
DEMOCRATIC VOTES AND MAYBE LOSE
SOME REPUBLICAN VOTES.
BUT THAT SHE WILL GET THROUGH.
>> I AGREE.
I THINK SHE IS GOING TO BE MADE
TO RESPOND ABOUT BLACK SITES AND
ENHANCED INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES FROM A LONG TIME AGO
AT HER HEARING, THEY WILL MOVE
ON.
I DON'T THINK SHE WILL BE
OPPOSED.
ANYTHING COULD HAPPEN.
SHE COULD END UP WITH A GAMBLING
PROBLEM OR BEING INVESTIGATED
FOR FINANCIAL CRIMES BUT AT THIS
POINT, IT LOOKS FINE FOR HER.
>> I THINK POMPEO IS CONFIRMED.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MANY
REPUBLICANS SHE LOSES.
JOHN McCAIN, RAND PAUL,
LINDSEY GRAHAM, MAYBE MIKE MIKE
LEE.
SOMEWHAT POSITIVE THINGS SAID
ABOUT HER BY SOME DEMOCRATS ON
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WHO
WORKED WITH HER.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN, WHO IS A
FIERCE OPPONENT OF ENHANCED